let's jump into this first story now
this was uh this was this was difficult
because we have a couple big stories we
have Democrat press secretary for Katie
Hobbs Jocelyn Berry resigning but we
also had news earlier in the day from
Matt Walsh uh I think most of you know
who he is if you don't he is a prominent
conservative commentator he put together
the documentary along with the daily
wire crew and many others what is a
woman challenging gender ideology he was
supposed to speak at Washington and Lee
University but due to threat let me just
read the tweet for you says sadly I have
to postpone my speech at Washington and
Lee University due to threats against my
family and other serious security
concerns in Nashville this week I cannot
leave my family and fly to another state
I hate to push the event off but my wife
and kids come first I intend to continue
my spring College Tour as planned in the
coming weeks the event at Washington and
Lee will be rescheduled as soon as
possible the threats to my family only
make me more determined to fight this
evil and will not let any harm come to
my children or my wife and I will not
let these Psychopaths scare me into
silence neither of those things will
ever happen I promise you in case it
wasn't clear this has nothing to do with
Washington and Lee University the event
was coming together well and everything
was perfectly fine may have been some
protests planned but nothing major the
potential danger is at home which is why
I need to be at home so things are
getting absolutely crazy we have many
conservative commentators banned on
Twitter still for calling out this trans
day of Vengeance and it's a re it's
really weird I was thinking about this
earlier obviously we had this tragedy
that happened on Monday the psychopath
goes into a school slash Church kills
children and faculty members
and then what do we see there's a viral
video going around Libs of tick tock
posted of a trans activist telling
people to get weapons and to go
physically beat people it's it's I've
never seen anything anything like this
typically when uh let's go back in time
when we had Andy know get attacked you
actually at the corporate press come out
and be like okay okay this goes too far
now you actually have the corporate
press coming out and saying well the
real victims here are the trans
activists despite the fact they're
sending death threats to the family of
Matt Walsh and planning a violent action
a day of Vengeance starting Friday into
Saturday and Sunday I call it a day of
Vengeance but another thing it's gonna
be three days they're saying it's still
going to be happening but this is
backwards I I just don't understand this
that it's everybody else's fault that
this individual went out I mean right
now the the person that perpetrated this
crime and killed six people is being
equated to a victim what what what is
going on I I just I don't understand
what has happened in this country we are
literally less than 48 hours from a
major tragedy and somehow the mainstream
media has turned the person that
perpetrated this crime
taken six innocent lives into somehow of
a victim and when we're sitting around
having this debate and I just a mind my
mind is blown going what is going on how
old are you 51 51. so here's what I
think is happening
the older generation that was raised off
the internet
is they have a similar view of the
country be it left or right liberal or
conservative but the Millennials who are
raised online are hyper polarized yeah
so the reason why I think we're seeing
this happen is that Millennials are
starting to take over these industries
be it Media or otherwise and they are
hyper polarized their world is so
dramatically different from your world
as soon as they take the reins of the
editor editor-in-chief position or the
executive editor position start making
decisions on how articles get framed or
what stories get covered this is what
you start to see I know I think you're
right I mean that's that's exactly there
is this dichotomy in in the in the
country right now where young and old
see the world differently it's about
patriotism who views the country as
patriotic I mean the poll that came out
the other day in the Wall Street Journal
that that shocked the heck out of me 38
of the country views patriotism and I
literally you know a bunch of people I
knew said well I wasn't shocked at this
and I said you weren't shocked I I get
the division but there was something
that I thought United us and that was
being able to say okay I'm an American
and I mean maybe I didn't think it was
70 as I used to but I thought maybe it'd
be in the low 60s 38 and I think that
you put your finger on it Tim this idea
that there's a huge divide between
whether we grew up with the Internet or
without it and and that's and I I mean I
see it every day but it's I don't know
maybe this is what's manifested the the
idea that you can see a tragedy like
this
and then say
here's the that the person who
perpetrated it is also a victim and I
was reading some of the statements today
and and from some of these groups that
you mentioned earlier and they were like
there are two victims in this and I'm
like no there's not
no it is never acceptable you took out
innocent lives there's there's it makes
no sense why someone whatever the reason
may be would kill nine-year-olds yeah it
just doesn't make sense no what you know
any year olds what the leftist activists
are posting on Twitter is that they were
future fascists I'm not exaggerating
Andy no has covered this they are
posting that that there are people on
the left saying that's a good thing
because the future fascists were stopped
but this is this is the point you're 51.
when your demographic when Gen xers and
boomers are no longer in control of the
system either through retirement or
passing on this country will fall into
abject Civil War if we take this
seriously I mean if people are saying
crazy stuff online and we're like he
said he was a dog
fence to say that this person is a
victim somehow sure obviously they were
drugged by someone I mean that's in that
way they were victimized Ian the issue
is the corporate press is writing puff
pieces for this person it's not it's not
about and that's as Sean says unheard of
it but but this isn't look I get the
left-wing groups maybe or or the
left-wing media there was a piece in NBC
News Yep this isn't some Fringe
organization or some Fringe media piece
this is a one of the the three major
broadcast organization that is somehow
giving a platform of sympathy to a
killer yeah yeah I think you have to
draw parallels to uh the relationship
between uh religious radicalization and
the online community you'll hear people
say I remember being taught this in
college that uh you'll have migrants
from move to you know France and they
are the first generation of family to go
to school there but they don't feel like
they are French and they don't feel like
they are part of their their Heritage
they're not from their country and so
they look online for acceptance and
community and they're more likely to
become radicalized that way and
radicalization often calls for violence
to carry out your beliefs and so this is
something that I was taught over and
over again at my University uh this is a
pattern that we see with people who are
radicalize and it's the same thing
that's happening with people who grew up
in extreme gender ideology they seek it
out online they feel uncomfortable they
look for community and the community
says you are being attacked every turn
and you need to make sacrifices you have
to be willing willing to act on this I
think something that many conservatives
and many in the older generation haven't
asked themselves is when the people
these these Millennials and genziers who
hate this country
they hate it with a passion when they
start taking over companies what will
this country look like
so a few years ago Colin Kaepernick took
a knee during the national anthem and it
was a controversy within the span of
only two or so years every major sports
team every major athlete was told to
take a knee that is a culture Revolution
overnight and only now are that there
are there are athletes who are saying no
to this and they are the controversial
ones now think about that flip it is
going to keep happening because it this
is what I think people don't realize in
2015 Donald Trump starts running for
office
a child who is 10 years old will be
voting next 10 years old then who had no
listening of politics their their their
developmental years is all being raised
by a media lying about Donald Trump
lying about the conservatives in this
country and the right and now they're
going to vote for the first time in
2024. that degree of influence is going
to keep getting more and more dominant
and as gen x's and Boomers retire and
pass on give it 10 20 years and you're
going to have two different
factions in this country you already do
but here's the issue
among Millennials in gen Z the
bifurcation is clear far left extremists
are calling for more violence in
response to what happened on Monday
something would be shocking I mean we
wouldn't tolerate this 10 years ago
everybody would come out and be like
okay look man we know we have our
differences but this goes too far not
anymore and it's because the younger
generation is gaining more and more
power in Industry that's the natural
flow of things it has nothing to do with
people becoming radicalized it has
everything to do with young people
already being radicalized on these
platforms of course that's why we see in
schools these teachers trying to teach
critical race Theory and radical gender
ideology because they are trying to
indoctrinate them at a young age
they will grow up they plant those seeds
they put the glitter in the carpet that
never comes out and those kids don't
need any more guidance so give them 10
years it's done you know it's funny for
the longest time I had this belief that
one of the mistakes that conservatives
made was not going into high school and
colleges right and then I said part of
the problem is that students aren't
exposed to conservative ideas and
thinkers and then we see what's going on
and I saw this myself I after I left the
White House I went to 20 college
campuses and I saw firsthand the idea of
getting shot at shadowed down right and
I know Matt is saying that part you know
he's not going to Washington Lee not
because of them but because of nothing
but the goal right now of the left is to
not allow
the those voices to be heard whether
it's you know me and and all these
authors that Brave books to be able to
go in to talk to kids or people like
Matt Walsh and and some of the other
folks to go to college campuses the idea
is to to not allow these kids that
you're talking about who are going to
vote to even know that there is another
point of view we want to shut them out
but the idea that you're you're also
talking about this idea that these folks
are talking about violence
something that the left used to abhor
they're now talking about this this
weekend having these getting guns and
going out and getting people and again
where is the leadership from the top
saying this is unacceptable the
president United States has been asked
to comment two days in a row not only is
he joked about it but he hasn't
condemned the violence that the left is
talking about coming out and and seeking
retribution now because they're his
people exactly it's it's he you know I
don't think Joe Biden is like a staunch
leftist but he gains power from these
groups and they are willing to tolerate
him if it destroys the right that's why
many of these you had some prominent
leftists to make videos saying you got
to vote for Biden back in 2020 and it
was weird he's like a corporate
establishment politician but he's closer
to them so he knows he gets some benefit
from their politics which is why
Democrats pounded to them so what does
he care all right it works it works for
him right he's just a vessel he knows
did you hear about Merrick Garland
ordering uh uh Marshall's not doing
arrested right because it benefits them
right I mean the funny part is when he
gets asked about this uh these slides
that were instructing the marshals he
says I don't know anything about it well
you were the guy that claimed just a
while ago that you were the ones who
instructed the marshals so on the one
hand whatever it was a year ago you're
claiming you were the one who ordered
them you had to give the order but when
it came to the instructions to the
marshals you knew nothing about that the
instructions it said let the protesters
do what they want I mean it's funny how
he only knows so much thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time